Hi, this is your host Naomi.
I'd like to show you the top 5 destinations of the United States.
Number 5: Boston.
One of the most historic cities of the United States,...
...it has some of the finest academic institutions and many quaint charming neighborhoods.
Number 4: Los Angeles.
See the famous Hollywood landmarks,...
...shop alongside the rich and famous,..
...and hang out with the locals at pristine beaches.
Number 3: Las Vegas.
It's the entertainment capital of the world.
On the famous strip amidst the glitzy lights,...
...you will find the exciting casinos, dining, shows, and nightlife.
Number 2: San Francisco.
The beautiful city is set in spectacular natural settings.
World-famous landmarks, scenic vistas, and wonderful climate define San Francisco.
And number 1: New York.
Among the world's greatest cities,...
...visitors rave about its unbelievable energy.
Everyone should experience New York City in their lifetime.
Keep watching our travel video series.
See you next time!